[Applauso]
primo dicembre
1955 siamo a montgomery in Alabama Stati
Uniti
e un gesto un semplice gesto ha cambiato
per sempre la vita di milioni se non
miliardi di persone
non è una guerra non fu una lunga
campagna politica né tantomeno una
manifestazione violenta e sanguinosa ma
un gesto un gesto portò avanti una di
una signora di appena 40 anni di nome
Rosa Parks cosa ha fatto questa Rosa
Parks per cambiare così drasticamente le
nostre vite da 60 anni a questa parte
ha detto no
no a cosa No ad alzarsi sull'autobus può
sembrare una cosa assurda in un certo
senso quasi ironica quasi simpatica
che tutti quanti oggi ci possiamo sedere
dell'autobus ma in america nel 55
c'erano le leggi segregazioniste Ciò
significa che i neri si potevano sedere
sull'autobus Ma se un bianco regalava un
posto in nero si doveva alzare il rosa
quel giorno disse No io non mi alzo Sono
stufa sono stanca
Rosa Paz fu poi portata dall'utore da
giudiziario fu imprigionata Ma quel
gesto scatenò una serie di movimenti una
serie di manifestazioni capitanate poi
da Martin Luther King che portarono a
una serie di cambiamenti E infatti un
anno dopo nel 56 l'America dichiarò
incostituzionale il fatto di non dare
diritto alle persone di colore di
potersi sedere sull'autobus bene Questo
è quello che nel libro di Ryan Holiday
il coraggio Chiama un grande un
grandissimo odore di bestseller
americani
viene definito come coraggio contagioso
cioè il coraggio che si espande come un
virus sta dando di virus parliamo sempre
in questi ultimi due anni bene un
coraggio che si è espanso
oggi non sono qui solamente per parlarvi
di coraggio Sono qui per parlarvi di
coraggio applicato ad un'altra parola
molto potente la parola ricerca ma
ricerca di cosa
ricerca del nostro obiettivo chiunque di
noi dentro nel profondo ha un obiettivo
da ricercare più soldi più successo più
amore più salute chiunque di noi oggi
nel profondo cerca di raggiungere un
obiettivo cerca di raggiungere qualcosa
ma la ricerca applicata al coraggio è
probabilmente uno una delle associazioni
un binomio di una tale Potenza da
generare imprese incredibili perché da
quando noi siamo nati da quando siamo
bambini ogni volta ci dicono che dietro
ogni grande impresa ci sia un grande
coraggio non basta il coraggio deve
esserci una ricerca ponderata razionale
di quello che veramente vogliamo
ottenere questo unito a una enorme dose
di coraggio ci Consente di raggiungere
qualunque obiettivo noi vogliamo
raggiungere
questo l'ho scoperto sulla mia pelle era
il terzo liceo e
parto con la ricerca dopo
un'interrogazione andava male in fisica
non so perché non so per quale motivo ma
dopo questa ricerca
presi un tre assi a un 3 e mezzo Insomma
comunque un voto veramente un voto
veramente osceno tornai a casa quindi se
a piangere e dissi a mia madre Mamma
voglio fare l'imprenditore Voglio
ricercare il mio obiettivo di fare
l'imprenditore non so cosa era nato ma
passarono appena tre anni e io a 19 anni
il primo anno è uscito fuori dal liceo
mi sono messo in proprio deciso di
avviare la mia attività di avviare la
mia impresa
era un'impresa nel settore turistico Ma
questo poco importa perché andò male
andò male dopo appena un anno e mezzo
alla miss in liquidazione falli
completamente il primo progetto Era
fallito adesso io avevo applicato la
ricerca ma probabilmente oltre ai poca
competenze che si può avere a 19 anni
forse non avevo messo il coraggio Forse
non avevo messo quella parola così tanto
potente Non è riuscito dalla mia comfort
zone Non è riuscito ad avere
effettivamente quella dose di coraggio
che molti di noi oggi bramano e infatti
il 20 aprile 2016 fu un giorno che
cambiò per sempre la mia vita la mattina
misi in liquidazione la società il
pomeriggio mi chiamo un mio amico Guarda
a un hotel di lusso nel centro di Roma
cercano un magazziniere e io
ciò che fece accetta un posto alla
magazziniere uno può dire Ma perché vuoi
fare l'imprenditore perché accettano
lavoro così tanto differente Qual è qual
è l'obiettivo vero Io avevo
semplicemente una cosa nella testa non
sapevo minimamente che impresa avviare
Non sapevo nulla di nulla ma ho detto
voglio uscire dalla mia comfort zone mi
metto a fare il magazziniere poi mi
hanno messo a fare anche altre mansioni
come lavapiatti come lo scaffalista
erano un lavoro molto
[Musica]
molto pesante la sveglia delle 4:30 di
mattina si lavorava 10 ore al giorno si
tornava a casa e si studiava ma Quella
fu una delle esperienze Anzi è
l'esperienza più importante della mia
vita quella che mi ha lasciato di più
perché mi ha lasciato così tanto perché
grazie a quell'esperienza che ho potuto
capire veramente
il valore del sacrificio il valore dei
soldi di quei pochi che prendevo che
reinvestivo poi nel creare quella che
oggi è la mia attività principale
rinunciando a ogni tipo di
svago ogni tipo di vacanza e la rinuncia
è stato un altro grande
caratteristica importante Un altro
fattore importante della mia vita che ho
scoperto grazie appunto a fare il
magazziniere bene Da quel momento in poi
applicando ricerche il coraggio qualcosa
di buono è veramente successo perché
infatti Poi appunto con la prima impresa
che è andata bene Ce ne è stata una
seconda che andava bene e ogni volta
quando sto per fare un qualcosa che
nella mia vita ha rilevanza in termini
di raggiungere un obiettivo piccolo
grande che sia applico sempre questo
binomio applico sempre il binomio della
ricerca col coraggio uscire tanto fuori
dalla comfort zone è probabilmente una
delle batoste ma al contempo una delle
lezioni più importanti che nella nostra
vita possiamo avere
Infatti
quando poi dopo un anno iniziai a
fatturare mi licenzia come magazziniere
e mi prese un altro rischio perché
uscivo di nuovo dalla mia comfort zone
avevo comunque uno stipendio seppure
Comunque non era un grande stipendio ma
ero uscito di nuovo dalla mia comfort
zone per prendermi un ufficio farmi
carico di un ufficio però quella sera di
nuovo parlandone con con mia madre il
punto fu rischia ora che sei giovane che
non hai niente da perdere
buttati fatti male Questa è stata
Infatti mi licenziai come magazziniere e
apri il mio primo ufficio a Roma
il punto veramente importante non
riguarda tanto l'obiettivo che ciascuno
di noi ha Possiamo diventare
degli ottimi fisici
dei grandissimi atleti dei grandi
imprenditori non è importante cosa
vogliamo raggiungere ma è sempre
importante ricordarci Per quanto
riguarda il passato
quante volte nella nostra vita abbiamo
applicato questo potente binomio
perché oggi noi tutti noi
siamo non altro che il prodotto di
questa scelta passata di questa di
questo binomi applicato Non applicato
quindi appunto vi voglio lasciare questa
sera con una domanda da domani mattina
quando ci svegliamo
quante volte pensiamo di applicare nella
nostra vita nella vita di tutti noi
la parola ricerca unita una grande dose
di coraggio Grazie
[Applauso]